why do you like films that explore the
theme of life and death I mean I think
the reason I got interested in making
art in the first place is to deal with
you know fears and and sort of
existential ideas and to get a better
understanding of like what it is to
exist
um and what it is to relate to other
people and so you know those kind of
existential ideas are are um the things
that drive me to create art that I love
in seeing in art and the things that
drive me to create art so when I'm
looking at films I absolutely love
thematically driven films and um you
know the the sort of meaning of life I
guess for for lack of a better way to
put it and the idea of what you know
what we're facing how do we face death
what does it mean to die
um how do we experience that is it
really interesting topics to me
can you remember one of the first films
that you watched that explored that and
you you know you talked about music
earlier and how sometimes music just
would speak to you whereas an actual
conversation you wouldn't receive that
feeling right yeah I think one of the
first films that really connected with
me thematically or sort of with this
type of uh connection is the uh the film
Phantasm and um it's it's really an
exploration of grief and it's really
about this this kid it starts out
there's a young boy who lost his parents
the parents have died they don't really
you know get get into it too much that's
what the starting point of the film
um and it's about his kind of way of
coping with that and there are these
kind of forces and there's the
um there's his the I would call it the
manifestations of his like worries about
what what has happened to his parents
and those kind of manifest as this this
evil Undertaker who's stealings
Souls basically and bringing them to
enslave them in this other dimension
it's a very strange kind of concept but
it but it really spoke to me as a kid
because it's like what would a little
kid how would a little kid come to terms
with the idea of like their parents no
longer existing what does that mean what
what would they be afraid could have
happened to them Beyond just their
non-existence and I remember seeing that
as a young boy and I I had no idea what
to make of the film first I mean I've
seen it you know a hundred times and I
still have no idea what to make of the
film in some sense
um but it really connected with me and
it was something that I remembered after
for a long time I wanted to kind of live
in that world and kind of explore it in
my mind in a way that I had not done
with other films you know uh there are
films that I Revisited as a kid like I
love you know Star Wars or something but
it never connected with me in that in
that type of way
do you remember who introduced you to
that film uh I think I saw it on TV I
just you know was was I loved
watching you know weird horror movies
monster movies I loved staying up late
and kind of looking at the the channels
and my parents were mostly tolerant of
me doing being being a weird kid and
doing all that kind of stuff
um so yeah I think I just I just ended
up seeing it you know on TV and then
later uh one of my close friends and I
we basically just spent every day going
to the video store and like looking
through the the horror section and the
kind of cult movie section to find you
know what is the strangest looking thing
that we can that we can find and I
definitely Revisited Phantasm in the
other films in the series as part of
that process
what are the complex questions
about life and death right
um
I mean I think ultimately we're all
trying to find some purpose in life uh
we're all trying to find some way of
understanding what we are uh why it is
that we experience the things that we
experience why it is that
um
other people don't always kind of mesh
with us what you know why we have
trouble communicating these internal
ideas
and ultimately you know we all I think
that even people who say they don't fear
it and maybe they create stories that
make them fear it less I think we all
kind of fear the unknown in general and
so you know when we think about death we
don't really know
what it feels like you know what what it
seems like the concept of of life at all
I don't think we really understand what
does it mean to be sentient
um doesn't mean anything are we just
basically you know machines that that
function are we the same as like a rock
essentially but we sort of have these
these functions these chemical functions
that sort of make us perceive ourselves
as something you know more more
meaningful
um and those are all things that you
know I think are pretty Universal to
people I think every Everybody kind of
explores those ideas and so for me uh
you know
I want to be able to relate to people in
our understanding of those ideas and I
think some people approach that through
something like religion or other kinds
of uh explanatory approaches to it where
they say here's okay here's what happens
like this is what happens when you die
this is what here's how you were created
and you know here's what life means this
is you know they hear the rules
um but none of that ever connected with
me so you know I'm looking for something
that's that's different from that and I
find that the abstraction that's
presented in film and in storytelling is
a really uh a great way for me to
explore that
what is theme
theme I think is the underlying idea
of a film and I know that idea sounds
sounds vague but I think the underlying
way that that film
connects to us in an internal meaningful
sense
and um I I often talk about theme and
thesis like they're sort of intertwined
and I know some some people will kind of
divide them uh
in a in a more strict way but I think of
theme is this sort of underlying idea
and thesis is what the filmmaker or the
Storyteller believes about that idea
wants to express about that idea and um
I love the the the the approach to
filmmaking or to storytelling where you
say what is the the the concept that I
want to explore what is the idea that I
want to explore what is the fear that I
want to explore what is the experience I
want to explore and then what is it that
I want to share about my own thoughts on
that experience what is it that I want
to share about my fears uh related to
that experience and that's going to be
my thesis and um when I'm writing a
story and I have characters in the film
maybe those different characters they
all should they all should be related to
that that theme their behaviors their uh
their kind of feelings their approaches
to things and the plot Arc as well
should all be related to that theme and
they may have all different ideas about
that theme they may have all different
manifestations of that theme and
ultimately me as a Storyteller I'm I
think if you're doing a good job you're
siding with somebody or you're you're
saying that you believe you have some
belief you're not just saying here's a
bunch of stuff to think about you're
saying here's a bunch of stuff and
here's what I think about that and
that's sort of the thesis approach to it
and that's how I like to structure
stories
same a big part of your writing process
it's a very big part
um I
think it's the most important thing I
think it's the the part that
meaningfully connects with people
um I think
if you're not writing for theme I don't
I don't want to criticize writers too
much but I think if you're not writing
for theme all you're doing is
emotionally manipulating people you're
just basically saying I'm gonna
create characters that go through
experiences that emotionally manipulate
you so you experience those emotions you
know empathetically or so on but it
doesn't really to me that doesn't really
serve a purpose what serves a purpose is
causing the viewer or the reader
depending on the context to be
introspective about their relationship
to that theme or that idea and their
experiences with that and then to be
able to express to them what it is that
I think about it or what what I where
what I'm maybe maybe even now what I
think but what is most important to me
about that theme or that idea and I
think that's a meaningful way again to
to connect with people and to have some
kind of push and pull into so you know
ultimately the goal is that when
somebody leaves the movie if they if
they watch a movie that you've made they
walk away with something to think about
and explore and to to make their lives
better in some way
how do you incorporate theme into
stories
well usually I start out with a theme as
a you know at the ground level at that
sort of nugget level of Storytelling I
think about what is the the topic that I
want to explore so I know a lot of
people are like oh I have this idea for
a story this is the character this is
what they do you know so on for me it's
more often like this is a really
interesting kind of topic
now this is the topic I want to explore
here's what I think about it now how do
I create characters and how do I create
a story that helped me to explore that
um
so maybe that's an opposite approach of
many people who are like oh I've got
this character I'm going to put them in
this world and now maybe I'll think
about a theme later I'm more like what
is it that I want to say why don't
because to me if I don't have something
I want to say why am I making the movie
right why bother making a movie if
you've got nothing to say I guess if
you're you know it's just revenue or you
know but you're making a popcorn movie
to get paid or something like that
that's fine and there's nothing wrong
with that but for me if I'm if I'm
creating something that's our kind of
real creative art
um
I have to think about what's important
to me at this moment how do I want to
express that and then how can I build
that from that idea and so every
character Behavior every character uh
typically takes a different perspective
on that theme that's that's one of the
approaches I have I say what you know
here's here's a character
how would this character relate to this
theme how would they behave in
association with this theme here's
another character
um
maybe it's a contrastive character for
example I mean you might be a
protagonist antagonist but it might not
it might be other types of characters uh
how do they relate to this theme how
would they behave in association with
that and now what is the story that
allows me to kind of go on a journey
with those characters that reinforces
whatever my thesis is associated with it
so again that that the beginning and
ending are really important to me
because
um
you have to tell the audience where
you're starting
Place everything set it up there and
then at the end you have to drive home
what is the thesis what is the idea that
you want them to to walk away with uh
and some of that is maybe because I come
from academic writing so I'm used to the
the idea of you know writing uh a kind
of a persuasive academic article and
it's really that that same type of type
of approach you know you're trying to
tell somebody here's what I believe in
in the scientific realm here's the
evidence of that and then here's the
conclusion so a symmetrical story within
a certain theme is more important to you
than just this is a great character and
I wonder what would happen if a b and c
entered their life yeah it really does
not characters don't interest me in that
way typically I'm I very rarely am
thinking like oh here's a character I
love like what can I do with this
character and I know some people
approach writing that way and there's
you know that's totally fine as well
um but yeah no I'm rarely interested in
character I think character drama is the
most boring part of movies uh I don't I
don't like watching movies that are
driven by character drama because
I feel like again it's just manipulative
it's just it's just sort of like I want
the if I want the viewer to experience
something I can throw a character in and
I can make them sad or I can give them
heartbreak or I can give them illness
and that to me is just an emotional
manipulation it's not it's not a
meaningful kind of Storytelling and
sometimes people like those kind of
movies and sometimes I like those kind
of movies where I'm like I'm just gonna
have an empathetic experience with a
character totally fine
but for me the the the better art or the
more meaningful long lasting art is one
in which
um
the character serves that theme the
character really they're they're a
manifestation they're a symbol they're
they're sort of a metaphor for something
else that you're trying to explore
is there a way we can further pin down
what theme means is there a movie that
we could think of that explains theme
sure I mean I I think you know every I
think every movie has themes whether
it's intended or not first of all so
some some writers will say well I didn't
write with any themes in mind I think it
you know there's something innate and
something that you're always doing as a
Creator as a Storyteller where you're
gonna themes are gonna emerge because
your subconscious ideas are gonna emerge
um one movie that I was watching
recently again and revisiting again for
the first time in quite a long time was
The Exorcist and I think the Exorcist is
a really interesting movie because
I remember it when I thought about it as
when I experienced it as a younger
person
I thought oh this is a story about a
girl who's possessed by you know a demon
and and this stuff happens and it's
really about like that possession but
now watching it I had a completely
different experience I don't think the
movie is actually
um really much about Reagan about the
girl at all uh the first you know
section of the movie is really about her
mother's experience with her child and
about the helplessness uh of of seeing
somebody you love you know go through
something that's that's difficult and
have a health of a health issue
um and so it's really exploring this
idea of like how does a mother deal with
uh not being able to help their child in
distress and it really the emotional Arc
really happens with with the mother not
not really with the child and then you
know we start to see the the movie kind
of shifts and and builds like kind of a
layered thematic idea where we see the
the priests
starts to look at
what it means to have faith what what
what is you know what does faith mean
can you really
maintain faith in the face of
um you know the most terrible thing you
know seeing seeing a child being you
know brutally uh treated this way
um and ultimately you know he he has to
kind of make a sacrifice uh he has to
accept his fate in order to you know to
to show that he holds faith enough
um he holds faith enough to sacrifice
himself you know to to
ultimately succeed in what he believes
in and so really it's you know the
Thematic ideas there are really you know
again about the mother's love for a
child and the helplessness associated
with the illness and uh you know the the
priests basically looking at doubt
right and and being taken seriously too
because right she had a lot of issues
getting people to believe well that's a
big thing yeah and it really I mean I we
have so many you know people now who
have so much so many struggles with the
medical system where you know they go in
and the doctor says nothing wrong with
you there's nothing wrong with you so
yeah absolutely I mean it's a really
really strong uh I mean I don't even
call it a metaphor it's literally
presented in the film but yeah it's
really really interesting exploration of
like what it means to have an illness
that's not really visible because they
you know they the doctors can't measure
it right they're trying to measure it
they're like we tested her nothing's
wrong with her none of those tests are
going to show that there's like a demon
possessing her right so
um yeah so I think that speaks to a lot
of people as well it's a very rich movie
I mean I think it's it's a really
fantastic movie and a lot of people sort
of think of it as like oh it's a horror
movie it's pretty good whatever but I
don't I wouldn't even I mean it's a
horror movie because these are these are
all horrific ideas I mean the mother you
know dealing with their child being sick
the medical system refusing to uh to do
anything about a sick child
um you know fighting with your own faith
and self-doubt these are all horrific
ideas and these are all kind of
universal existential ideas as well
do you think movies from the past maybe
30 years
were more theme driven
I think especially when you look at
films in the 70s I think they were
really really heavily theme driven and I
think you had a lot more of the sort of
flexibility within the studio system
where it was a little more auteur
feeling where filmmakers were allowed to
make things that were a little unusual
not necessarily structured
in a in a way that we can break down as
much as we break down kind of modern
films all kind of conform a little more
to a very specific structure and so I
think um when you look at those I think
they they all really feel you feel the
Thematic or the thesis-driven elements
of those films a lot more than you do in
modern films now that said
I think even you know my my least
favorite films right like the Marvel
films and all these superhero films they
have themes they they absolutely have
themes they have themes about you know
militarization they have themes about uh
you know the the I mean the Superman vs
Batman movie where they they destroy
everything their their themes about like
you know what is the collateral cost of
of fighting a war
um there are definitely are ideas there
that are that are interesting
um but I don't know that most viewers
are taking those ideas home with them or
uh or relating them to something
existential the way that maybe a lot of
the popular movies in the in the 70s
really connected with people